you're still at a phase in your life
where you can meet a giant celebrity you
haven't met before most people would
assume oh you've met everyone but right
no no no like the most recent one um I
was this is gonna be a very name
dropping I'm just telling you that's
good I like people like that you're
welcome in advance um I was at my friend
Tracee Ellis Ross is mother's birthday
party who might that be you asked Diana
Ross Diana Ross yeah I'd never met Diana
Ross and Tracy invited me to her mom's
birthday and I was very excited to go
and Tracy brings out this Kate was in a
very intimate Vinny like a hundred
people there and Tracy brings out a cake
for her mom and she says Beyonce if
you're still here do you want to sing
happy birthday and I'm like that's
hilarious if Beyonce is still here no
Beyonce was there wait yeah she comes
down the stair and like a standing like
as close to me as you are and she's just
as exciting I mean I was exciting and
she starts this level of excitement for
you you could tell you could tell it's
possible and wait so she wash something
and it's her it's her and she sings
happy birthday which is you know not a
hard song to sing doesn't have a lot of
range but I was like very good Beyonce
and then Justin Justin my husband was
like we have to meet her and I was like
I'm nervous I'm scared like what you
might not know who I am so I do this
thing called a drive-by where like I
just walked by someone and if they have
like it he's sort of like like oh it's
you then I look to see if they know they
run you yeah and if their eyebrows go up
low then you have an inexact yeah she
didn't give me that so I was like I'm
already so close to her like I have to
say something to her this is my one
opportunity when am I ever gonna be near
Beyonce again so I put my arm on her and
I go remember she just sing happy
birthday
not a wildly impressive song I put my
hand on her and I go beautiful
and she kind of looked at me like is
there more and I'm like beautiful that's
it that's all I say that and then what
happened were you just litter she goes
thank you and then she she walked away
she was really nice she smelled great
but like that that was my opportunity
yeah it was like that's it I was like
I'm sorry I'm sorry I choked yeah you it
sounds very much like you choked yeah I
once convinced my mom to do a drive-by
this is years and years ago this is
before I'm ever on television when I'm a
young writer out here in Hollywood and
my mom comes to visit me and she visits
me in this restaurant and we're and she
doesn't know who many celebrities are
but over in a corner booth is Bruce
Springsteen okay having dinner with
Patti Scialfa and it's like that's a
huge deal on everyone
mom that's Bruce Springsteen and even
she knows who does and she's like oh and
I said what do I want to get a closer
look and I said here you do mom you do a
drive-by you just walk by like you're
headed to the ladies room and then you
pass and you look at him when you go by
just to get a good look and then you use
the ladies room you come back and she
went oh do it and my mother gets up and
she walks by Bruce Springsteen and does
a really obvious like but then she keeps
walking and she gets to a dead end
there's no door there she gets and she
has no to do and Bruce Springsteen is
like looking like what are you doing
here here Bruce breaks in and she's like
and there's nowhere for her to go and
she turns around and comes back and I
think to this days like we were that
time that lady
just with a wall yeah I was laughing my
ass off yeah